[Musique]
bonsoir j'ai été élevé dans l'hémisphère
sud et donc j'étais exposé de ma plus
tendre enfance aux merveilles au ciel de
l'hémisphère sud
en effet notre galaxie la voie lactée
est beaucoup plus belle vue du sud parce
que c'est là où on peut voir les régions
centrales on voit aussi dans
l'hémisphère sud
les deux galaxies les plus proches de
notre galaxie qui sont les deux petites
tâches que vous voyez là en dessous qui
sont appelés les nuages magellan c'est
aussi dans l'hémisphère sud que l'on
peut voir une merveilleuse constellation
emblématique la croix du sud
cette croix du sud a illuminé je dirais
mais lui pendant mes campement quand
j'étais adolescente et tout cela m'a
donné envie de comprendre comment
fonctionne l univers et de devenir has
officielle et j'ai eu la chance de
pouvoir le devenir et de garder cet
emblème de la croix du sud puisque j'ai
été amené à diriger les eaux les eaux
qui est le grand organisme européen qui
a des observatoires pour les astronomes
européens dans l'hémisphère sud et qui a
comme un bol la croix du sud les diriger
les eaux entre 1999 et 2007
et ça m'a permis de retourner dans
l'hémisphère sud et d'aller au filet en
effet lorsque les eaux a décidé de faire
des observatoires ils ont cherché les
cieux le plus limpide du monde et ils
les ont trouvés au chili dans le désert
de l'atacama les oyats construit
successivement trois observatoires dont
le premier contient un télescope de 3060
qui est un très grand découvreur
d'exoplanètes
le deuxième c'est celui que vous voyez
sur cette photo c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'observatoire du mont paranal qui
contient quatre télescopes de 8 mètres
de diamètre qu'on appelle le vlt very
large telescope
et cet ensemble est le meilleur ensemble
de
et les scop du monde et obtient des
résultats extraordinaires et moi j'ai eu
la chance de pouvoir être si elle qui a
pu superviser la fin de la construction
du vlt la mise en place des instruments
le départ des observations et c'était
évidemment absolument passionnant alors
il faut savoir que en astronomie
le plus souvent les découvertes ne sont
pas faites juste avec un instrument ou
un télescope
sinon c'est la continuation de plusieurs
observations différentes par exemple
puisque intéresse on parle d'exoplanètes
était dit dans mon introduction et les
exoplanètes on en reconnaît maintenant
plus de 5000 la grande majorité sont
très très grande comme jupiter encore
plus grande mais on commence depuis
quelques années on trouvait aussi des
aussi petit que notre terre et en
particulier il ya un an ou deux il ya un
groupe d'astronomes belge avec un petit
télescope c'est sur le premier
observatoire de les eaux qui ont trouvé
un système autour d'une étoile d'une
toute petite étoile une étoile dix fois
plus petite que le soleil ce qu'on
appelle une naine rouge un système avec
cette planète toutes les sept dans des
masses comparable à la masse de la terre
alors immédiatement tous les instruments
du monde qui pouvait faire des choses
intéressantes sur ce sujet se sont
plantés dessus et on a beaucoup avancé
alors évidemment il ya une belle t il ya
eu aussi des instruments qui sont dans
l'espace parce que vous savez que vous
pouvez astronomiques dans l'espace on a
pu déterminer leur masse leurs distances
par rapport à leur étoile et on a pu se
rendre compte que parmi les sept
il y'en avait deux qui étaient à une
telle distance que si elle avait eu de
l'eau l'eau il y aurait été sous forme
liquide sel sont trop près l'eau
s'évaporer
elles sont trop loin logel rien là elle
serait sous forme liquide ce qui
évidemment le cas sur la terre qui était
donné dans le temps comme la grande
conditions d'habitabilité
aujourd'hui on sait que ça ne suffit pas
que cette condition tyan mais c'est
quand même quelque chose qui vous fait
penser que peut-être que c'est
intéressant de regarder de plus près
peut-être un jour tu auras ton de la
bilan des planètes de ce type
et donc je peux vous dire que tous les
instruments futur
ils ont étudié ce système qui s'appelle
trappistes un de très très près alors ce
système il est quand même à 40
années-lumière de nous c'est pas très
très loin pour un astronome mais c'est
quand même pas écouté qu'est ce qu'il ya
de plus près il y as proxima du centaure
et là le télescope de 3 m 62 les eaux a
découvert que autour de proxima du
centaure il y a également une planète de
masse comparable à la masse de la terre
c'est aussi une étoile une naine rouge
donc une situation tout à fait similaire
et là c'est à quatre années lumière
c'est ce qu'on peut avoir de plus près
et donc de nouveau je peux vous dire que
tous les nouveaux télescopes que nous
construisons vont aller étudier de plus
près ce système et on entendra sûrement
parler pendant longtemps alors ceci dit
on peut pas tout faire rien qu'avec la
lumière visible quand on veut comprendre
l'univers univers aimé des lumières a
beaucoup de longueurs d'onde et les
astronomes travaille depuis les ondes
eux les plus énergétiques les rayons
gamma jusqu'aux les moindres énergétique
c'est-à-dire les ondes radio et chaque
domaine de longueur d'onde vous permet
d'apprendre des choses différentes
en particulier si on s'intéresse à la
question de la formation des étoiles et
des planètes
alors on veut aller regarder à
l'intérieur de grands nuages de gaz et
de poussières et ses nuages absorbe la
lumière visible donc de toute façon dans
le visible
on les verra pas ce sont des régions qui
sont beaucoup plus froide qui mettra des
longueurs d'onde plus longue c'est
intéressant de les observer entre des
longueurs d'onde entre 0,3 micron et et
1 cm le problème c'est que cette lumière
là elle nous arrive donc depuis les
étoiles et il faut pas traverser cette
passe faire pour nous arriver et
l'atmosphère fait tout pour l'arrêter et
en particulier la vapeur d'eau dans
l'atmosphère absorbent ces rayonnements
et c'est pourquoi en général on se
disait la seule façon de le faire c'est
d'aller dans l'espace
si on a effectivement lancé des
satellites artificiels avec des
instruments pour pc observation mais sur
un satellite artificiel vous pouvez pas
mettre télescope énorme et quentin tesco
petit c'est comme si vous voulez
ramasser de l'eau de pluie si vous avez
un petit saut vous aurez un petit peu
d'eau
si vous voulez ramassé beaucoup d'hommes
mettrait un grand saut grand soin on
peut pas l'être dans l'espace on voulait
donc pouvoir faire ça sur terre et on
s'est mis à chercher un endroit sur
terre où on pourrait faire des
observations à ces longueurs d'onde là
donc qu'est-ce qu'il fallait peu
d'atmosphère surtout peu de vapeur d'eau
les astronomes de des états unis les
astronomes d'europe les astronomes du
japon se sont mis à chercher venaient
tous trouvé un seul endroit dans le
monde et c'est le jannou de carpenter
qui est donc de nouveau dans le désert
de l'atacama papa juste à côté des
observatoires précédent de lezo morgan
dans la danse eux-mêmes énorme désert
alors les observateurs dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure sont à des
altitudes qui sont seulement entre 2500
et 2600 mètres dans une claque mais on
veut avoir très peu de vapeur d'eau et
aller beaucoup plus haut donc on ya 5000
mètres d'altitude
en même temps il fallait avoir une
grande surface parce que c'est
ces observatoires contiennent plusieurs
télescopes et la précision que l'on va
boire dans le ciel dépend de la
séparation entre ces divers télescope
si on veut une grande précision dans le
ciel il faut pouvoir les éloigner par
exemple une quinzaine de kilomètres donc
il fallait un plateau à 5 mm et ça
effectivement sur le fameux altiplano
des ondes ou des sacs que la donc voilà
le plateau de thierry thaure entouraient
de deux volcans qui ont encore 1000
mètres de plus au dessus de ce plateau
le problème c'est que là évidemment il
ya deux fois moins d'oxygène ici donc
c'est quand même pas très facile d'y
travailler donc déjà montés tous à
construire le ce qui est aujourd'hui le
plus grand observatoire du monde dans
ces conditions
ça semblait de la folie et pourtant nous
l'avons fait et dans les matches
suivants
vous voyez l'inauguration en 2013 de cet
observatoire
il fallait évidemment lui trouver un nom
et c'est bien simple puisque c'est un
ensemble de télescopes nous tease
l'anglais atacama large millimeter array
on utilise l'anglais parce que ce projet
n'est pas uniquement un projet de réseau
c'est un projet international puisque
c'est tellement vaste et il y avait
aussi les états unis le canada et
plusieurs pays asiatiques
alors alma ça fait aussi halm et
allemand en espagnol ça veut dire am il
nous semble un nom tout à fait approprié
pour ce merveilleux instrument
quand on va regarder de plus près à quoi
ressemble le télescope d'alma on se rend
compte que évidemment ces longueurs
d'onde là il faut utiliser les
techniques de la radioastronomie c'est à
dire que on n'utilise pas des télescopes
comme ce que je vous ai montré pour les
hommes et des antennes qui ressemble
tout à fait aux antennes d'être une
communication que vous connaissez tous
simplement celles là sont beaucoup plus
précises comme les longueurs d'onde sont
course qu'il faut une surface
extrêmement fine extrêmement précise et
il faut aussi suivre les mouvements d'un
vélo c'est une prouesse de la technique
que de construire ses antennes et de les
faire fonctionner le 5000 m ensuite en
fait on en a 66 presque tout avec des
diamètres de 12 mètres et toutes
ensemble
elle doit former un instrument et pour
cela il faut mettre ensemble les
résultats de toutes ses antennes et donc
il y à aussi à 5000 m un endroit où nous
avons un super calculateur unique au
monde qui en temps réel ramasse toutes
ces données et transforme tout ça est
fini par vous sortir une image
donc on en aura un exemple là si on ne
se pose la question de comment se
forment les planètes comment se forment
les planètes
donc là je vous montre une image qui
peut vous sembler pas tellement
intéressante à côté d'autres belges
images que vous avez bien en astronomie
et pourtant c'est une prouesse
extraordinaire je peux vous dire que
toute la communauté astronomique
mondiale est absolument amoureuse de
cette photo parce que ce que ça
représente
c'est une étoile très très jeune une
étoile encore en formation au centre est
entouré par un disque de gaz de
poussières très froid et c'est dans ce
disque que vont se former les planètes à
mesure que le temps passe le disque se
dissipe une partie de la poussière du
gaz 120 et le reste sera sentent sous
forme de planètes ou alors de ceinture
d'astéroïdes et là vous voyez le moment
où les planètes en train de se former
là on peut l'être se forme elle nettoie
tout ce qu'il y a dans le long de son
parcours
d'autres choses que l'on peut faire avec
calme assez de la spectroscopie
c'est à dire on peut essayer d'étudier
quels sont les constituants de ce qu'on
regarde et pour cela on décompose la
lumière dans tous ces petits éléments et
on reçoit la signature des éléments
chimiques ou des molécules ou des atomes
qui lie à dans l'objet que l'on étudie
alors alma est capable de faire ça même
avec des gars là sont des galaxies
lointaines ce qui est ici et d'y trouver
des molécules qui peuvent être parfois
des molécules organiques compliqué que
nous appelons des briques de la vie
c'est à partir de là vraisemblablement
que se sont formés les molécules de la
vie dans un autre exemple que je voulais
vous montrer
on a trouvé des molécules que l'on
pensait jusque-là être le résultat de la
vie pas les briques de l'abîmé au
contraire il n'apparaîtrait pas quand il
ya déjà de la vie et pourtant on en a
trouvé tout près d'une étoile en
formation dans notre galaxie
on ne la trouvait également sur la
comète que la sonde rosetta à commettre
ce jour là sont des étapes a récemment
regardez donc vous voyez on a beaucoup
de surprises
c'est ainsi que avec alma on a déjà
énormément de résultats jeune effectif
leur ai quelques-uns des résultats on
attend énormément plus avec alma nous
allons pouvoir comprendre comment ce
sont non seulement former les étoiles et
les planètes mais comment se sont
assemblés toutes les galaxies et ce sur
toute l'histoire de l'univers parce que
grâce à sa grande sensibilité
on peut regarder des objets très
lointain et donc on y voit comme il
était au moment de l'observation il ya
maintenant 10 milliards
ou 12 milliards d'années on a des
surprises on découvre que même dans des
galaxies très lointaines c'est à dire
que l'univers était très jeune il y
avait déjà des trous noirs absolument
gigantesques qui ont des masses
comparable des milliards de fois la
masse du soleil et ça vraiment c'est une
surprise totale
et finalement on a des projets très
ambitieux comme par exemple avec l'aide
d'alma et de un grand nombre de
télescopes dans le monde entier
essayez de faire l'image de l'ombre du
trou noir central qu'il y a dans nos
autres la version est beaucoup plus
petit mais beaucoup plus près et c'est
encore un rêve que nous avons
[Applaudissements]